what what do you think
uh the biggest since we're covering
every single possible topic let me ask
the biggest one
the unanswerable one from the
perspective of alien intelligence
or from the perspective of religious
studies or from the perspective of just
diana
what do you think is the meaning of this
existence
of uh this life of ours yes okay so
all right so
[Laughter]
well of course i have to my
philosophical training as
uh undergrad always makes me think about
like
what's the assumption in your your
question the ques there's an assumption
there it's like there is a meaning
okay that's the assumption by meaning
what do you mean by life yeah you define
the terms
no no but listen okay i'll answer your
question i'm just gonna say that there's
this
assumption that we should have meaning
to life okay well maybe we
we shouldn't maybe it's just all random
okay however
i believe that it's not and in my
opinion and the meaning of life
in my opinion is intrinsic i enjoy
living i want to live sometimes i don't
enjoy living and when i don't enjoy
living i change my circumstances
so it's intrinsic and i think that
certain things are intrinsic and
like love love of your children is kind
of um
well it's actually physiological but
it's also intrinsic it's beautiful
you know there's something about it that
that is
intrinsically um desirable
so that i i think the meaning of life is
like that intrinsically
desirable so it's something that just
is born inside you based on
what makes you feel good no that's
hedonism
that's about what where do you place
love love
love of your children yeah so basically
um loving your children by the way is
not always
easy because they do things that they
shouldn't do
you have to discipline them that's one
of the worst things about parenthood to
me
is disciplining my children i don't like
to do that i love them
so a lot of things that i do that i feel
are good are not easy so there's an
intrinsic sense
that like okay let's take um
animals okay so we have dogs and cats
okay so you might not but i do i've
you know i told you about them can you
can you uh share their names if i share
their names i will share their names
okay
so we have a cat and it has red fluffy
hair
and so he called it trump well when we
got our dog
we figured that it needed a companion so
we called it putin
so we have trump and putin that's the
greatest pet names
of all time i'm sorry yes
and maybe we'll be able to share a
picture of your cat because this is
awesome it is really cute yeah
very photogenic uh
i mean is this something that's uh
whether a lot
whether we're talking about love or the
intrinsic meaning do you think
that's something that's really special
to humans
or if there is intelligent alien
civilizations out there
do you think that's something that they
possess as well
uh maybe in different forms like
whatever this thing
that meaning is this inter
intrinsic drive that we have do you
think that's just
a property of life of some level of
complexity
that we will see that everywhere in this
universe
in my opinion and this is just my
opinion um i
i do think that it is but i also think
that it can take different forms
so if there is like uh think of gravity
right gravity kind of like
makes stuff stick to it right it
contracts stuff
well what is loved you that does that
too right so people who
are cr we call them charismatic charism
it means love charism means light and
love
so a charismatic person is a person who
attracts people to them
like the sun does right like you know so
um
so i think that whatever this property
is that's intrinsic
is like gravity and most likely takes
different forms
in different types of life forms yeah i
can't wait until
like uh albert einstein type of figure
in the future will discover that love is
in fact one of the fundamental forces of
physics
that would be cool diana
this is one of the favorite
conversations i've ever had
it's truly an honor to talk to you and
thank you so much for spending all this
time with me absolutely it's been fun
thank you
you